begin with what is the premier game for
thanksgiving all due respect to the
texans and the lions and washington and
the cowboys although
the the tryptophan bowl first place
became much more interesting after both
washington and dallas won on sunday but
the game that was the main course for
thanksgiving night now undermined by the
news that the ravens have a couple of
players who have tested positive running
back mark ingram running back jk dobbins
the chances of either of them being back
for thursday night minuscule because
they've tested positive it's one thing
to be placed on the covet 19 reserve
list because of close contact with
someone you can come off of that in two
days we saw that happen with vikings
fullback cj hamm in as few as two days
it's five days after your last exposure
to someone who's positive but if you're
positive you're not getting back that
quickly so
people are thinking well will the game
be postponed could they play it on
sunday can they play it on no the nfl's
approach
has become and i think it started with
the buccaneers raiders game several
weeks back get the games in you're down
a guy call a man up you need a guy sign
somebody find somebody you have to be
ready to go it's on you to field a team
and if you're down one guy five guys ten
guys i don't know what the critical mass
would be we haven't seen more than six
or seven and usually guys who are gone
in bulk a lot of them come back anyway
shireen but the nfl has determined
they're going to get the games played so
even without mark ingram even without jk
dobbins hey you still have gus edwards
you still have whoever else may be on
your roster you can call guys up you can
sign somebody can go get ray rice again
if you need to whatever it takes you
have to field a team you have to be
ready to go we are getting this game in
we are not going to vacate that window
we are not going to be in a position
where we have to pay back nbc the value
of having that game to a captive
audience on thursday night period
hey play lamar jackson at running back
play rg3 at running back you have
justice hill you have gus edwards go
play with with what you have and that is
kind of their approach mike but it just
seems like we've we're just right on
that edge right now of having to go to a
week 18. uh it we're just so close i
mean every day guys go on and this guy's
testing positive it's not just close
contacts it is guys testing positive and
we know from the general population that
people are testing positive the numbers
are spiking and thanksgiving is coming
and it's just going to escalate and
roger goodell sent out a memo last week
warning that thanksgiving week was
crucial and it is crucial for the nfl
and i'm not going to be surprised mike
if in the next two to three days the nfl
is very concerned right now but if in
the next two or three days they don't
tighten things up at facilities even
more than what they are now we know the
whole nfl is on this intensive protocol
approach to things at the facility but
you still have people in their business
people the media still goes in uh the pr
people are still in that building
they're gonna tighten this thing up in
the coming days and just say essential
personnel need to be in the buildings
that's all that's the only people
allowed in the buildings
yeah and they already are ratcheting
things up by putting every team in the
enhanced protocols had been hatched for
only teams that were having issues i i'm
with you they're going to keep making it
harder and harder to get in they're
going to keep doing what they can to
keep people separate when they're in
there you have to assume that everyone
else has it that needs to be the mindset
that's the only way
to ensure that the guys who inevitably
will get it won't take others down with
them period and of course now we have
another test case of whether or not the
virus can be transmitted on game days
out in the open whether it's to
other players on the sideline and you
know it's been several weeks now that
the nfl has strongly encouraged physical
distancing mask wearing when on the
sidelines and you will see countless
times in every game guys sitting
elbow to elbow when they're not on the
field guys with no masks guys with masks
serving as a jowls catcher guys with
masks that are drooping down so their
nose is exposed so you may as well not
have one on at all what's the point
they're not complying and then on the
field you can't comply titans again back
on watch for whether or not they may
have had some sort of exposure and
ultimately have guys on their defense
who test positive because of mark ingram
and specifically jk dobbins who's
emerged as the the lead running back so
they're not out of the woods there
they're not out of the woods when it
comes to the people showing up at the
facility every day and the danger this
week and i saw bruce arians talking
about it this week where if you're going
to have people in town for the holidays
get them tested too no
don't have people in town for the
holidays
and and that that's a thing
the cdc
can repeat the mantra until they are
blue in the face no one i don't want to
say no one some are but the people who
are hell-bent on living their lives and
throwing caution to the wind they're
going to have people in town they're
going to continue to not care about it
and that's where we have to worry about
next week and the week after you know if
the nfl can hold it together through
thanksgiving that's hardly the end of it
we have to see how the incubation period
from this weekend plays out into next
week shireen
yeah that's absolutely right mike and
you have to be careful with having
people over because
unless you're being tested every day a
negative test tells you nothing i mean
you look at what happened in the game
yesterday with dobbins and ingram they
tested negative but then their day of
the game test came back positive today
so they didn't know they had it
yesterday but they did and they still
played and dobbins played 41 snaps and
ingram played six snaps and they were
out on the field and the nfl continues
to insist that it cannot be transmitted
on the field they do not believe it can
be transmitted on the field from player
to player and as you said mike this is
being tested out again we have another
test case so far their their theory has
proved to be true we don't know of a
case that has happened on the field
between players but you're right they
have to do a better job on the sidelines
and everywhere else they are of wearing
masks and i do see more compliance but
it's not full compliance and until you
get full compliance
until you have players doing the right
things not having family in town all
those sorts of things this is going to
continue to be a daily news item who's
going on the list today
yeah at one point the cdc revised its
guidelines from 15 consecutive minutes
in the presence of others to a
cumulative 15 minutes of being around
someone else the viral load is part of
this and that's why the nfl became
concerned a couple of weeks ago about
sideline because you are in close
contact with teammates and coaches on
the sideline for a far greater time than
you are actually in close contact with
opponents during a game to the point
where the droplets are in the air and
they are invading your eyes and your
nose that's the primary pathway that's
the primary area of concern sidelines a
far less safe place actually in all of
football
the safest place very well may be the
playing field on game day it's
everywhere else where you can have the
transmission sidelines locker rooms
meeting rooms airplanes buses etc and
that's what they've been dealing with
they've held it together it's been four
weeks now since a game was even adjusted
that buccaneers raiders game went from
prime time to late afternoon just for
fear that that it would be derailed
we've seen an end to double headers on
monday night football we saw one tuesday
night game because they just want to get
the games in and if you are down a man
or two or three at a position it's up to
you to go out there and get guys who can
come in and get it done so i think they
will play thursday night but now the
ravens who are desperate for a victory
are gonna have a harder path to beating
the steelers and i know shireen that
three weeks and one day ago after they
played the steelers there was a strong
belief within the ravens organization
that they kicked the
four letter words starting with s and
ending with it out of the steelers
well
they still lost and since then they've
lost two more and this ravens team is
kind of wobbling on the edge of the
cliff right now this could be the thing
that pushes them off
yeah mike this is my the team i picked
to win the super bowl before the season
unfortunately i know you picked the
bucks i had the bucks going in the nfc
but they to me don't even look like a
playoff team forget a super bowl team
they don't look like a playoff team and
they are desperate for a win and if
they're going to stay in the playoff
race they have to win this game and i
don't know how they're going to do it
against this steelers defense which we
know is so very good lamar jackson's
going to have to take a lot on his
shoulders and he's going to have to play
much much better than he has at all this
season he needs to play like he did last
season if they're even going to have a
chance to stay with the steelers the
steelers are playing at a different
level mike going into this year we
talked about the covet being a huge
factor the team that had the fewest
coveted cases that could stay the
healthiest and stay coveted free was the
team that probably was going to win the
super bowl and you look at the
pittsburgh steelers and what they've
managed to do health-wise and
coveted-wise and that's why they are
where they are or a big reason why they
are where they are
and i really wish that the two sides
management and labor would decide
simultaneously we just need to put
everyone in hotels for the rest of the
regular season and then for the 14 teams
that make it to the playoffs for the
rest of the postseason because this same
concern we have now about thanksgiving
gatherings resulting in a delayed
reaction rash of of positive cases and
potential outbreaks sharing we're going
to be having that same conversation when
christmas rolls around it's going to be
the same issue people coming in town
people being around other people just
kind of being loose and celebratory and
maybe a little eggnog and maybe a little
wine and maybe a little of both and
that's when people start to drop their
protective shield that will keep them
from from getting too close to somebody
getting themselves exposed and then we
could have outbreaks happen just as the
playoffs are unfolding so it needs to be
an area of concern and the sooner they
get everybody in hotels the better off
they will be and yes this is an
advantage for the steelers and the
steelers have had their issues but not
like some of these other teams and now
the ravens dealing with a major issue as
they try to avoid falling to six and
five from 14 and two last year to six
and four this year
and we saw the schedule they get past
the steelers if they can find a way to
win it they are going to be very
desperate they're going to be dangerous
any any nfl team is more dangerous when
desperate on the other end of it there
are some winnable games there and it's
weird to think right now the browns are
ahead of the ravens in the division
because the ravens beat the browns 38-6
to start the season but look at that
cowboys browns jaguars giants bengals
even if they lose to the steelers and
fall to six and five eleven and five
isn't out of the question and eleven and
five even though it kept the patriots
out in 2008 when there were six teams in
the postseason field in the afc you
would think 11 and 5 would get the
ravens in
yeah absolutely mike and if they are on
a five-game winning streak or a six-game
winning streak going in the postseason i
think you like their chances a lot
better
than them winning one and losing two and
whatever the case may be but they've got
to get on a winning streak and it needs
to start now and they really do need to
beat the steelers but if they don't
you're right they still got a good
chance to make the postseason based on
that schedule especially with what's
happened with the bengals at the
quarterback position and other things
like that but they do need to get on a
roll here pretty quickly to stay in this
thing
right now the baltimore ravens and the
miami dolphins would be on the outside
looking in and look at the browns at
seven and three and they should finish
ten and six maybe better maybe they beat
the ravens who knows it's ugly it's not
inspiring it's not exciting but it's
effective and good for the cleveland
browns and we're happy for the folks in
cleveland minnesota is another area of
covet 19 concern just this afternoon
adam thielen star receiver had a couple
of touchdowns yesterday he's had one
hand it catches galore lately he is on
the covet 19 reserve list which is
unfortunate for a vikings team that i
think is now down to its last chance
gotta run the table to to even have an
opportunity to get in in the nfc i don't
think nine and seven is going to do it
this year too many good teams in the nfc
especially in the nfc west and also the
bears have placed eddie jackson on the
reserve covet 19 list so
this is just a constant stream it's
non-stop it's going to be this way we've
come to accept it we're numb to it there
is that difference though between a
positive which is definitely going to
knock you out for a week or longer and
the close contact exposure which you
could be back in a day or two you could
be back in five days who knows but this
is just part of the reality for the nfl
we have grown accustomed to it
and we just deal with it it affects
steam teams strategically but they're
going to do everything they can to keep
it from canceling games
yeah absolutely mike and eddie jackson
was a close contact so good chance he
could be back on sunday if he continues
to test negative we don't know about
adam thielen but there is a big
difference between testing positive uh
and being in close contact and so we
have seen some of these close contacts
they won't get to practice like the
raiders we've seen a bunch of these
cases with the raiders they don't get to
practice but they do get to come back
and play in the game and and that'll
affect some of them and some of them it
won't i thought the raiders played
pretty well defensively despite not
having all those guys out there
yesterday of course patrick mahomes is
patrick mahomes but i don't know that
practice would have changed what
happened at the end of that game last
night and i thought they played
relatively well against the chiefs
overall despite not having practice for
most of those starting defensive players
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports